[Applause]
[Music]
the Netherlands is one of the lowest
lying countries in the world and believe
me when I say that these are really
really low loans
[Music]
[Applause]
the average elevation is only 30 meters
and a quarter of Dutch territory is
below sea level this also makes the
Netherlands one of the country's most
under threats from possible rising sea
levels caused by global warming
but it's not the most threatened country
as many of you will know the Maldives is
most at risk with an average altitude of
just two meters this is incredible
especially if we consider that despite
being a flat island in the middle of the
ocean its capital male is one of the
most densely populated cities on the
entire planet having said that we're
gonna leave the Maldives for another
occasion because in this video we're
going to focus on the Netherlands and
some of the most ominous predictions
that are currently faces you may have
seen images like the one appearing on
your screen right now
images models and maps showing how most
of the territory of the Netherlands
including its capital Amsterdam will
disappear under the sea as a result of
melting polar ice caps logically it
would follow that such an event would
eventually force the Dutch to emigrate
on mass to neighboring countries like
Germany because according to scientific
estimates the sea level could rise
between thirty to seventy seven
centimetres by the year 2100 the worst
case scenarios predict a rise of 200
centimeters and even though that may not
sound like much those centimetres they
really do count not only because a rise
in the sea level would flood many lands
as low-lying as the Netherlands but also
because as it would multiply it the
flood damage for example causing floods
and river overflows when storms occur
this of course would translate into a
loss of human lives destroyed crops and
cities flooded lands etc
[Music]
however just a second because in this
video we're going to show you how the
inhabitants of the Netherlands are
already working to face this gigantic
challenge dealing with the rising sea
level it's a problem for which they only
really have two options the first is to
find the water building a higher levees
larger or more resistant dams and more
powerful containment infrastructure the
second option is to embrace their
neighbour water and try to control and
live with it as we should no we're
talking about a country with a lot of
experience in the matter people living
on the lands that we currently know as
the Netherlands have been suffering the
effects of huge floods that periodically
ended the lives of dozens to tens of
thousands of people for centuries even
before the Middle Ages take the flood
that occurred in 1287 that took the
lives of between fifty to eighty
thousand people and you know what even
back then they already had containment
dams a hydraulic achievement that was
quite advanced for the time we talked
this was more than 700 years ago so as
you can see this is a population that is
very used to living with and fighting
against water and now the big questions
that crop up are how on earth are the
Dutch preparing for the future are they
fighting a losing battle can the
Netherlands even survive global warming
if the poles partially melt and raise
the sea level
[Music]
natural risk or human risk so it's no
surprise obviously rising sea levels are
a great risk for the Netherlands and for
much of the world and it's true that if
there's one thing that characterizes
human beings it's our ability to adapt
face adversity and overcome virtually
any risk than nature throws at us right
now that threat really is on the table
so what exactly is the risk we're
talking about right now is the sea the
risk or are we the humans the real risk
[Music]
this map shows the areas that the
Netherlands has reclaimed from the sea
since the 14th century as you can see
that Dutch have been swallowing areas of
the sea for centuries building cities
and planting crops in areas with a high
risk of flooding areas that were once
underwater Arryn's could well be again
one day after all the sea has been
redrawing the map for millions and
millions of years the waters have
advanced and receded in till we got more
or less the map that we know today which
was completed about 6,000 years ago in
geological time 6,000 years was
practically the day before yesterday
however now the problem emerges because
the pace of natural warming has
accelerated due to human activity in
order to understand the worldwide
situation and specifically that of the
Netherlands better we can say that we're
facing two major challenges and the
truth is that both are fundamentally
man-made the first challenge is to slow
global warming to levels as close as
possible to natural warming and the
second is to avoid occupying high-risk
spaces such as polders which are lands
that have been reclaimed from the sea or
flood plains near rivers which are areas
susceptible to natural floods so let me
ask you a question if I build my house
in flood zone next to a river and one
day a flood comes and destroys my house
is it my fault or is it the fault of the
river and the flood
perhaps from a general point of view
many of us would blame the river but in
the Netherlands they have a deep-rooted
culture of coexistence with water to
some extent they know that they are the
guests then is they occupy a place that
the sea used to occupy and in which they
need to continue coexisting and that's
what makes the Dutch a bit different do
you want some concrete examples well
let's take a look
[Music]
the battle against the sea strategy
change
if the inhabitants of these lowlands
have learned anything over the years
it's that fighting against the sea is a
losing battle a certain failure sunny
explained the strategy of protecting
themselves through dikes dune barriers
dams and reservoirs to control rising
sea levels has been used for centuries
the greatest example of this public
strategy of protection against the sea
was the Delta Works project developed
after the great flood of 1953 that
killed almost 2,000 people in the single
night the project was completed in 1997
with the construction of a gigantic
barrier near Rotterdam with twin gates
as large as two Eiffel Towers that
rotate on tracks to seal the waterway
they take two hours to close over the
past two decades the barrier gates have
not yet been use to contain any massive
flooding but the Netherlands pushed the
Delta plan forward with the aim of
creating effective protection for at
least 200 years but hold on a minute
because we're overlooking something the
Delta plan is a project from the last
century and the truth is that over the
last decades knowledge about rising sea
levels and their effects has increased
that's exactly why the Netherlands has
now changed its perspective you see
after Delta watch the Dutch have
switched from planning for more and
higher levies to planning for controlled
floods in fact very recently in March
2019 they finished construction on the
room for the river project a huge
project with a budget of about three
billion dollars this is a project that
is sought to expand the river
floodplains whereas a high overflow risk
basically it involves diverting flood
waters to control areas and it sounds
pretty sensible
[Music]
one of the best examples we can find of
this is in drag spaulder a fundamentally
agricultural polder in which they've
created a large aquatic recreation area
however as you can imagine leisure isn't
the main objective of this huge body of
water and canals rather it's designed to
absorb and contain water during floods
and large storms it is close to
Rotterdam and it's also the lowest point
in Netherlands so it's one of the area's
most likely to flood in the entire
country
this kind of reservoir is designed to
prevent spread of water during the
overflows of the Rhine River which is
expected to happen periodically once
every 10 years but don't think that's
the end of it because apart from the
noob holders that are capable of
absorbing floods the Dutch government's
policies and those of its cities go much
further
Dutch engineers have been preparing the
country for decades keeping a worst-case
scenario in minds and always thinking
long-term we're talking 100 200 or even
a thousand years and that's a great way
to prepare in Rotterdam one of the
cities with the highest risk of flooding
they are creating a large number of
public spaces to evacuate water and thus
help prevent a lot of damage for example
there's the creation of water squares
such as the Bentham plane an area that
in case of floods or storms turns the
lower areas of the enclosure which
usually holds leisure and sports
facilities in such gigantic swimming
pools that can hold up to 1.7 million
litres of water all of that water
instead of causing a great deal of
damage can drain gradually to avoid mass
flooding but there's still more even
garages are being designed as water
tanks in case of an emergency the
fundamental idea in Rotterdam and other
vulnerable cities is to create as many
controlled water tanks as possible to
safeguard homes and major infrastructure
that is do allow flooding but to control
it and all of this will greatly reduce
economic costs after a natural disaster
or a major weather event
and the best part is that both citizens
and politicians share this vision I
can't just keep building higher levees
because we'll end up living behind
10-meter walls we need to give the
rivers more places to flow protection
against climate change is only as strong
as the weakest link in the chain and the
chain in our case includes not just the
big gates and dams the sea but a whole
philosophy of spatial planning crisis
management children's education online
apps in public spaces harold von waiver
and dutch government advisor and we're
still not done and what may be somewhat
more controversial the government is
expropriating agricultural lands from
farmers to create controlled flood zones
they're doing this without asking for or
searching for volunteers farmers just
have to leave safety above all at least
that's what they say
however many of these farmers are
seeking an opportunity to change to
create something new and to adapt to a
future with more water in the
Netherlands and it's also true the
compensation money has also led some
farmers to retire but there are much
other more curious reinvention examples
such as the invention of floating farms
with financial support from the city of
Rotterdam the balidaan company has
created the first floating dairy farm at
the moment sits only a 2 million euro
prototype 40 cows that could produce
half a million litres of milk per year
and perhaps if the costs were lower
inventions such as this would allow the
Netherlands to alleviate some of the
problems that the elimination of
agricultural lands for the benefit of
waterways can pose for its economy they
are after all the world's second largest
exporter of agricultural products second
only to the United States with more than
90 billion euros in exports in 2018 as
you may have gathered from this video a
dutch won't give up easily
they have always lived side by side with
water and it seems that they'll continue
to do so and many generations that's why
they've been adapting for the worst-case
scenarios for decades a sea-level rise
of up to 77 centimetres or even more by
nor should we be surprised by the huge
capacity for adaption that human beings
have shown when faced with all kinds of
scenarios the point is that it doesn't
look like the Netherlands will disappear
underwater at least not in the coming
decades the apocalyptic scenario they'll
only occur if the Dutch stands still for
decades or centuries without acting and
today here we've shown that that's
simply not the case obviously that
doesn't mean that global warming isn't
challenged indeed as a challenge that we
all have to address and overcome however
what we have wanted to show in this
video is how some societies have already
begun to prepare for tomorrow's world
and out perhaps looking for solutions is
better than getting carried away with
sensationalism and now it's your turn
the Netherlands will be with us for a
while that case as soon as clear but do
you think the time will come when not
even the most advanced technologies will
allow the Dutch to live in their country
and in your country's case how do you
think the government and society would
respond to such a challenge well leave
your answer in the comments and I really
do hope you enjoyed this video please do
hit that like button if you did and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos also please do check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
but we're not mine also this channel is
possible because the patreon owns our
patrons on that platform please do
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]